solo desde el inicio de la invasión rusa
14 millones de personas han tenido que
huir de sus hogares qué planes está
implementando el acnur para atenderlas
en medio de un conflicto que no parece
tener una salida a corto plazo
bueno hemos aumentado obviamente nuestra
presencia tanto dentro de ucrania como
en los países vecinos donde están
llegando
la gran mayoría de los refugiados
ucranianos y recordemos que la inmensa
mayoría de ellos son mujeres y niños y
este es uno de los conflictos en el
mundo que aunque he hecho que el número
de personas desarraigadas hombres
mujeres y niños que han perdido todo a
causa de la intolerancia de la violencia
de la persecución alcance la cifra
récord en la historia de 100 millones de
personas 100 millones de vidas
destruidas de vidas de personas
desarraigadas en el mundo es realmente
un día muy triste cuando no tenemos que
presentar esta estadística pero cómo
puede prepararse el mundo para un éxodo
tan veloz como el que ha vivido con la
guerra deberían los gobiernos
implementar planes de contingencia ante
posibles eventos similares
bueno esto es una situación bastante
especial la liga de ucrania no siempre
serán estos movimientos tan grandes en
tan poco tiempo nosotros sí tenemos
contingencias y se ha respondido
bastante con bastante eficacia a esta
situación
y lo que realmente se debe hacer es
mantener este nivel de respuesta porque
si bien hemos visto en el caso de
ucrania ha habido una respuesta muy muy
fuerte muy muy potente por parte de la
comunidad internacional no siempre es el
caso y no olvidemos que hay muchas otras
situaciones en el mundo que requieren
igual
respuesta por parte de la comunidad
internacional y no solamente por un día
o una semana o un mes tenemos
situaciones que llevan años décadas
incluso en donde generaciones de
refugiados continúan sin poder volver a
sus países y es por eso que no solamente
es la respuesta humanitaria que es
esencial para salvar vidas pero también
una voluntad política que de encontrar
una solución de acabar con los
conflictos de promover el diálogo de
evitar que harían estas persecuciones
estas violaciones a los derechos humanos
son esenciales si queremos realmente
resolver esta situación justamente usted
lo estaba mencionando y voy un poco a
nuestra región cuál es la situación de
los desplazados y refugiados en américa
latina' una problemática que lleva
décadas
así es tenemos en nuestra región también
situaciones de desplazamiento
interno como es el caso de colombia pero
también tenemos situaciones de personas
que han tenido que dejar su país por una
serie de circunstancias no
necesariamente una guerra como podría
hacer el caso de venezuela donde es una
crisis compleja una crisis social
económica política
que ha llevado a más de 6 millones de
veces de venezolanos y venezolanas a
dejar su país tenemos otras situaciones
también muy preocupantes como son las de
centroamérica en donde personas que
vienen de honduras al orden agua de
guatemala han debido dejar sus sus
países y buscar protección o una mejor
vida en otros países de la región
entonces también en nuestra región vemos
esta situación de desarraigo de la
desplazamiento del éxodo de millones de
personas que tienen que dejar sus
hogares ya sea para desplazarse dentro
de sus países o hacia otros países
caxito son en nuestra región también muy
preocupante